all right hi everyone
really nice to be here choosing a
walk-up song is always a little bit
difficult whether it should be through
mattock with the talk is what I went
with this time but last time I went with
mrs. Robinson which was a big hit when
it landed on the mrs. Robinson and
everyone realized what song it was yeah
I so but today we'll be talking about
funnel join which is a package that I've
created along with Dave Robinson and
Anthony Baker that to do define a tidy
grammar of funnels in our so what do I
mean by a funnel a funnel is a set of
events by users over time so let's take
a few examples let's say you're an
e-commerce company redesigning your
homepage and you want to understand the
behavior and who are these users
visiting this homepage some things you
might want to know about them include
what were the pages the last page people
saw before coming to this homepage or
you might say and said what happened
afterward what product pages did they
see if you're an e-commerce company you
care a lot about conversions people
actually buying so what is that
conversion rate and what if you limit
that to a two day window so these are
all questions looking at users in this
case visitors to your website
understanding their behavior whether
that's pageviews or conversions and over
a set of time but it doesn't just have
to be people what are some other
questions we can ask in this way of this
kind of first this happened then that
and we have an identifier for who did it
and what the event was in the time well
I had solicited some potential questions
from people and I got some interesting
answers like which salmon migrated to
station 1 then station 3 to station 2
this is a question that ecology
researchers might ask and understanding
the migration patterns what drugs do
people take in the last month before
starting another drug to make sure that
you can capture any interactions what
was the last ad people clicked before
they registered or what companies had
their stocks hit a hundred and then
dropped to 40 so right these are
companies
salmon's cetera it's not just people and
they all have in common this type of
structure of the question so let's take
a specific example when was each users
first landing and then the first that
then their registration first
registration afterward so we have two
fairly small simple tables here which
just has landing registration and the
user who did it and the time now
currently if I asked you to answer this
question your work fool might look
something like this you'd first have to
filter to get the first landing per user
then you need to left join with the
other table registered on user ID but
remember we only want those
registrations that happen after the
landing so you've got a filter to make
sure that the registration times greater
than landing or in some cases you want
to keep those who don't have a
registration and finally we need to
filter for the first row of the
registration because we only want their
first registration afterwards now this
was a little you know this was a fair
amount of code probably something most
of you could code up but let's say then
I switch up the question a bit what
about who registered for the first time
ever after their first landing so not I
don't want to keep people who had their
second registration after they landed I
just need it to be their first ever so
now we've got to change it up a bit you
say let's filter now for their last
landing because I'm saying I only want
their last landing and then first time
ever registration so we change up and
add the descending then I need to join
again with registered but I need to only
join on the first people's first ever
registration and finally again I do that
filtering so this is a place where a lot
of errors can come in write your copy
and pasting some of the code but you
have to remember oh I got to change it
to descending oh I have to make sure I
only get the first-ever registration and
there's a lot of room for error here and
it's also can be a little difficult to
think about it it's not super easy to
switch between these two types of
funnels and that's why we created the
funnel joint package you can find it on
github it's not yet on cran
but we've been developing it for about a
year and a half so it's pretty mature
now and this is meant to solve these
types of issues let's take a look how it
does that because the goal of this talk
for you and funnels is maybe
for now this was you this is cinderblock
the cat who's trying to lose some weight
and as you can see is not very
enthusiastic about this prospect
so maybe with funnels you're like yeah I
guess I can do it I really don't want to
be here but right after this talk this
is gonna be you you're gonna start
taking your first steps you're like I
can do this you know this is all fine
and then finally tomorrow because I
promise you funnel join really is that
simple you will just be going and
leaping over any problems that you
encounter so that is what I hope for you
to all take away from this talk
what's Ivan to funnel join what is this
magic package well let's take that
question we had what was that first
landing and the first registration
afterward so here's how funnel join
addresses this question with the after
join function let's break it down piece
by piece so first we start with a table
1 which of these tables is the first
event in this case landed then we take
table 2 registered we want to do a left
join so we could add it as an argument
but funnel join you can just write after
underscore left underscore join just
like you could have right inter etc then
we say what are the user columns that we
were joining what's the unique
identifier for it could be people again
company salmon what are the time column
names how do we know when these events
are happening and then finally the type
of after join the first four arguments
here probably look pretty familiar right
we're used to this when we're joining
any tables we have to tell it what the
tables are what are the columns we join
it on but what is this type thing so
this is new and this is what funnel join
is contributing here so what type here
is saying we want the first landing and
there first after registration we can
look at some different types of funnels
let's say this we have this user Jim and
this is Jim's behavior on our website
with ad clicks and conversions these are
all happening over times we see he has a
conversion that an ad click another
conversion 3 ad clicks 2 conversions
what are the types of questions we might
ask about Jim's behavior we could say
all right what was Jim's first ad click
and his first conversion afterwards so
here we go we highlight his first I
click I would go and link that to the
first
conversion this is the first first after
join we just saw but then we might ask
instead what's his most recent act click
what's the last one and then all the
conversions
afterward so here we highlight his last
add click then we link it to the
conversion afterward well we link it to
the second one as well this is the last
any join we take the last side click and
any conversions that happen afterward
finally maybe we want as big a funnel as
possible so we want to link all the add
clicks and all the conversions that
happen afterwards so here everything is
highlighted
except that conversion that happens
before any add clicks because again
we're defining all conversions must have
happen after the act click but here we
end up having many links so then this
isn't any any type of join so we see
here is that we can specify all of these
different types of funnels a first first
after a last any in any any because
depending on the type of question that
we're asking funnel join comes with 16
types of funnels that are any
combination of first last any and last
before and first last any and first
after so you can combine you can have a
any any as we saw last before first and
so on again to really give you
flexibility and easily switch between
different funnel types and to show this
a little bit more I'm actually going to
do a live demo based on a blog post I
wrote using stack overflow data so let's
switch over to that can we switch up
there baby
if not I can see I can just go this way
I think there we go all right so let's
take a look here we have of course we
always start off loading the tidy verse
and then funnel join the package here
I'm gonna be loading in these answers
and questions from sack overflow data so
if I go ahead and take a look at this
what this is I'm just going to zoom in a
little more so these are people all
these questions tagged with our you can
download this data from Cavill so we
have here the exact type of thing we
need we have an owner user ID who is the
person answering this question and what
was the creation date when did they
answer it and similarly we have the
questions data set which has the same
type of thing so one question we might
ask is how many people ask a question
later answer one so how many people
actually here have ever answered a Stack
Overflow questioned alright I got a
small amount of people how many folks
have asked them yeah a good bit more
right so I'm not too surprising more
people ask questions and answer them so
but how do we quantify that so we're
gonna go and take the questions and
we're gonna do an after left join with
answers because we want to keep all the
question askers we're gonna find that
the user column is owner user ID the
time column is creation date and now we
have the type of joint so in this case
we want how many people so I need this
to be one row per person so I'm going to
do a first their first question and then
who answers a question afterwards so if
I go ahead and run this we'll get a data
set of 60,000 rows which is a number of
unique people and we can use another
funnel join function summarize
conversions that will take something
that is and use that we identify is the
column that indicates whether or not
there was a conversion and calculate
some statistics before I do that I want
to use a little trick that I actually
wasn't familiar with but you can before
making this package but is present in
deep fire you can add a suffix so if I
don't want these dot X's and dot Y's to
indicate for columns that are common
between the two tables but weren't join
which one it came from I can instead say
I want that to be underscore question
and underscore answer just to make it a
little cleaner and now I'm gonna say
alright well I know that creation date
answer is only gonna exist if someone
answered a question so let's see alright
we find that of the 60,000 users in this
data set who asked a question tagged
with our twenty two point seven percent
of them later answered one but let's
change it up a little bit how long did
it take those people to answer their
first question so I'm going to go ahead
and copy this and now I can i can add
the gap call argument and funnel join so
gap call says it's going to create a
column called gap which will give you
the time difference in seconds between
the events so in this case we see of
course we have n/a some people never
answered a question someone else
answered in 734 seconds someone else
many more seconds so we actually do a
quick visualization I'm going to mutate
to get the hours so I'm going to do gap
/ 360 and that I can make a quick ggplot
so I can say let's visualize the hour
gap by and we're gonna do a genome
histogram and now we can see this this
of course doesn't look very nice or it
does it looks fine but it's not super
easy to tell what's happening so
actually I cheat a bit I pre wrote a
little bit of code just to make this
scale better so I'm going to change it
to be a log 10 scale with breaks that
make sense with the time and we can see
that we have you know some people answer
within an hour
a good chunk answer within a day some
one week and some wait as long as a
month so if I want to say I can get an
idea from here like okay roughly what
percent of those who answered a question
answered it within say a week but let's
say I wanted to answer that right away
with funnel join so I could use I could
take funnel join and I can add an
argument the max gap argument so here
this is saying I only want to join
questions with answers that have a
maximum gap in time of this much so I'm
going to
it can take either an argument as
seconds or I'm going to use as DIF time
so I'm gonna say let's do 7 units equals
days and run that and we're gonna do
summarized conversion on creation date
answer and we'll see that here before we
had about 22.7% ever answer a question
and we see here that 8.8% answer it
within a week so finally let's switch it
up a bit you know here we've been
looking again always okay who asked a
question that answer it but there might
be a sort of strange population of users
perhaps that answers a question before
ever asking one do those people exist
and how many of those do we have so here
if I take the code that I've written I
can now go ahead and switch it over so I
have answers going first then the
questions because I want to know answers
or for questions change it to a right
join keep all the questions and now I
change to a first first join because I
want people I want to get their first
answer ever and did that happen before
their first ever question so here I
don't want to just know who and who
asked a question after they answered I
wanted to I want to know specifically it
must be their first ever question and
then if I use that I can see that and we
use again the creation date in this case
question and this case still answer and
I can see that in this case they're in
fact 4.6 percent of these users answered
a question before they ever asked one
now let's go back to the slideshow here
and I'll wrap wrap up the talk so here
we have in conclusion there are a couple
joins of the funnel joint a couple of
goals the funnel joint package beyond
taking you from cinder block being
really reluctantly exercising to the cap
cat leaping over the fence and the first
goal is to bring the impossible to the
possible now I put impossible in quotes
right because of final
is written in our these were all things
that you could have done but maybe felt
impossible to you you weren't really
sure how to do answer these types of
questions and coat it and coat it up but
I think more impactful is taking the
time consuming an error-prone to the
quick and easy again if we go back to
that first example of switching up the
type of funnel you could start copying
and pasting your code and remembering oh
I have to do descending because I want
the last instead of the first and I want
to change it to this join but it really
could end up being that you might
introduce some bugs that way but finally
going from having limited creativity to
asking and answering new questions so
the biggest benefit I found and I use
funnel join a lot now is that I am
asking a whole new set of questions that
I wouldn't have even thought of before
just because it used to be kind of
time-consuming and slow and I didn't
think of this way how many wickham's
often talked about one of the big goals
that ID verse is to help you fall into a
pit of success to make it easy and also
to let you iterate quickly that's why
ggplot2 is so powerful because it has
this grammar of graphics it's really
simple to switch back and forth between
different types of graphs which is very
important when you're doing an
exploratory analysis and here that's the
same goal we had with funnel join not by
making it so easy to explore these types
of funnels you'll start asking new
questions of your data if you want to
learn more I wrote a blog post on funnel
join that use the same Stack Overflow
data and asked a few more questions you
can look at that on my blog on hooked on
data org there also is a vignette on the
package down site Robinson is github do
that you can go to and find and of
course as I mentioned it's on github
underwrite github and finally with that
thank you all so much you can find my
blog as mentioned on hooked on data I'm
also on Twitter and I'm actually writing
a book as Jared mentioned on data
science careers which you can find at
data SCI career com thank you all so
much
[Applause]